this episode of the Y files is brought
to you by PDS
de Enoch warned the Giants and the
Watchers of the world repent or feel
God's Wrath they ignored his warning the
floodgates of Heaven burst forth and
water rushed over the Earth destroying
everything the only thing to survive is
a single vessel a huge ship the Ark 5
months later the waters recede and the
Ark made ground on a Mountaintop a man
named Noah Emer emerged and civilization
began again some version of the Noah's
Arc story exists in almost every
religion and every culture on Earth but
did Noah and the Ark really exist well
there's evidence that they did so much
evidence that it was classified by the
CIA for almost 50 years but why classify
it well there are two problems with the
Noah's Ark Story one the ark is much
older than anyone thought and two the
man named Noah he wasn't a man at least
not a man from Earth
[Music]
these aren't that weird I guess human
wonderful I can't talk long because I
got to get 200 units finished and out
the door by CB today well you called me
so I'm killing it with these camel toes
and I have to order more fabric stuffing
thread no skit bottoms labels boxes okay
hang on how are you making camel toes
aren't those what a slip is shaped like
gerti's feet oh what did you think I
meant well never mind look a Heckle fish
slip is a selling like hot cakes right
our Heckle fish slippers look humanin
you're selling something that allows
people to stick their foot inside me so
I think I could say hour uh technically
it's just your likeness yeah well every
time I see someone slip their foot
inside one I swear I could feel it all
the way up my okay that'll do thank God
those slippers aren't foodo dos huh I'd
never be able to sit down
again okay that's enough remember you
licensed your likeness to me to fund
that Heckle fish sings Vegas album oh
that's going to be big
somewhere beyond the sea somewhere
waiting for me my lover stands on Golden
s what do you want take it easy okay
look I need another Teensy wiy little
teeny tiny baby weenie loan of say uh 15
Lodge the bank turn me down because I
have too many credit cards and Loans but
I need the money so everyone can have
soft pretty little camel toes this
holiday
season okay one I'm not loaning you
$115,000 and B I'd seriously consider
changing the name of this product and
third why don't you just call PDS oh it
sounds like you're gracefully sliding
into today's
sponsor yep if you're making payments
every month and your balances aren't
going down PDS can help they roll your
debt into one low 0% interest monthly
payment you can save thousands in
interest and fees and pay off your debt
in a fraction of the time but my pile of
debt is high and my credit is uh not no
problem everyone with over $10,000 in
debt qualifies and there's no minimum
credit score required bad and Fair
Credit accepted perfect did they give us
one of those linky clicky things sure
did PDS is giving our qualified viewers
a free debt analysis for completing the
302nd online assessment at w ww. PDS
de.com files that's pdsd
ebt.com files you got it Perfecto I'm
going to stuff a camel toe in every
stocking okay you seriously need to
change that name got to go lots of son
to do the camel toe came bloting from
across the sea it Ling it there with
lots of hair well look at
me
James Bruce was born to a wealthy
Scottish family in 1730 his family
wanted him to study law but James Bruce
had different plans he had a dream he
wanted to be the first person to find
the legendary source of the Nile River
now this might sound like a mundane task
but for hundreds of years the race to
find the source of the Nile was as
gripping as the race to put a man on the
moon well nobody won that race what now
nobody went to the moon the whole thing
was faked I'm just saying the race to
find the source of the Nile was a big
deal then just say that don't give me
some cockamamy nonsense about the race
to the moon that never happened I was
just making a comparison well you made
it
[Music]
poorly Bru spent over a decade in Africa
tracing the Nile he traveled through War
torn deserts he befriended several Kings
and made enemies of others he fought
Savage tribes and survived deadly
disease diseases nearly starving to
death James Bruce discovered a small
spring it was bubbling from the earth
near a monastery in the T Highlands of
Ethiopia this was it the source of the
Nile River but Bruce discovered
something else something much more
important during his stay at the
Ethiopian Monastery he saw an old faded
manuscript on display It Was Written in
G an ancient semetic language used by
Ethiopian Jews James Bruce was told this
book was the Bible not a Bible the Bible
Judaism in Ethiopia goes back almost
3,000 years the Old Testament and Quran
tell of the Ethiopian Queen of Sheba who
heard about the wisdom and wealth of
King Solomon she was intrigued by these
reports and decided to travel to
Jerusalem to meet him for herself the
specifics of their meeting were not
specified but the Queen of Sheba was so
impressed she praised the god of Israel
and gave King Solomon many gifts she
brought Caravans of gold gems and spices
King Solomon grateful and equally
impressed gives the Ethiopian Queen all
that she asks and then the queen returns
home in the Old Testament and Quran
that's where the story ends but
religious texts in Ethiopia go into much
more detail when the queen finally made
it home she learned that Solomon gave
her one last gift a son ah King Solomon
the
player their son was menelik the first
when menelik grew up he returned to
Jerusalem to meet his father King
Solomon was so happy to finally meet his
son that he offered menelik the throne
menelik declined and chose to return
home but before menelik left some of his
men stole the Ark of the Covenant and
brought it back to Ethiopia there's been
a large Jewish population in Ethiopia
ever since according to the Ethiopian
Orthodox Church the Ark of the Covenant
is still in Ethiopia it's in the town
axom in the Church of our Lady Mary of
Zion and it's a great story and if you
want to hear it I've linked it below
back at the monastery James Bruce was
fascinated by these new texts Bruce was
a well- read well- educated man and he
knew his scripture but these Ethiopian
texts contained hundreds of stories that
weren't in the Bible not in his Bible
anyway the Ethiopian Bible contains 81
books the Catholic Bible removed eight
of those books and contains only 73 the
King James Bible the one known to Bruce
has only 66 books Bruce didn't
understand there was so much more detail
in the older texts people merely
mentioned once or twice in the modern
Bible had their entire lives documented
in the Ethiopian Bible their lives their
families their deeds their misdeeds they
were all there James Bruce didn't
understand why so much of the original
Bible was removed and then he
did while thumbing through the stiff
Dusty Pages Bruce came across the Book
of Enoch James Bruce knew Enoch as the
great-grandfather of Noah he was
mentioned a few times in the Bible but
only in passing here was an entire book
on Enoch 108 chapters now James Bruce
understood why the church wanted this
book hidden it described Heaven not just
as a spiritual place but as a physical
place that could be visited by men that
was heresy no mortal man is able to
visit heaven and certainly not able to
visit and return but Enoch did and he
wrote down everything he saw he didn't
describe heaven as Souls floating in the
clouds playing harps he describes it as
a city in the sky with many different
rooms with walls covered in gems of
blinking lights and Godlike beings going
about their business now Enoch wouldn't
have known it at the time but he was
describing a
[Music]
spacecraft The Book of Enoch vanished
from history thousands of years ago only
to be rediscovered in 1772 by James
Bruce while the Book of Enoch was
certainly interesting it was dismissed
by Muslims Jews and Christians and not
considered part of the Bible after all
it was hidden away on a mountain in
Ethiopia how important could it really
be if the Book of Enoch was truly
scripture there would be more copies of
it but there weren't but 150 years later
that would change in 1947 near the
ancient settlement of kumran a young
Shepherd happened upon a cave he was
looking for a stray goat and thought it
could have wandered in the boy tossed a
rock in the cave hoping to scare the
goat out instead he heard the sound of
Potter breaking within the cave were
clay jars filled with ancient Scrolls
almost a thousand manuscripts the
Scrolls cover every part of the Hebrew
Bible and there amongst the well-known
books was The Book of Enoch in fact in
ancient times The Book of Enoch was so
widely read and regarded 11 copies of it
were found among the Dead Sea Scrolls
they were intact complete and perfectly
match the text of the Ethiopian Bible
still The Book of Enoch is considered
apocryphal and not part of the Bible
apocryphal is a nice way of saying it's
fake some even consider the Book of
Enoch to be heresy a crime against God
when you read the book you can
understand why Enoch may actually be the
first case of alien abduction ever
documented one evening there's a strange
sound above Enoch's Village it's not
Thunder or wind it's a sound that seems
to make the air and Earth vibrate it's a
sound that can be felt the villagers
cautiously come out of their homes and
see a bright orb of light hovering just
above the trees slowly the sphere of
light descends upon the village the
town's people are terrified but Enoch
hears a voice tell him to not be afraid
Enoch then ascends to Heaven escorted by
a Celestial being named Uriel something
similar happens to the Prophet Elijah in
two kings Elijah is physically taken to
heaven in what he calls a chariot of
Fire
what it's easy to see that a man living
thousands of years ago would describe a
rocket or a spacecraft as a chariot of
fire that's enough okay okay sheesh what
a
grouch in abrahamic religions Souls of
the righteous go to heaven after death
maybe jesus takes them by the hand maybe
they follow a loved one through the
light or maybe they just arrive there
this is not what happens to Enoch like
Elijah Enoch is physically taken to
heaven and writes down everything he
sees he doesn't write this for memory
he's literally walking around with Uriel
writing things down he was instructed to
do so by God and although Enoch
describes this journey in religious
language he's also pretty scientific he
describes seeing mountains below he sees
every river on Earth he describes seeing
how the winds are made possibly
referring to cloud
formations Enoch sees all of this as
Divine but his account could be
referring to technology a smartphone
would seem Supernatural to someone
living thousands of years ago a
spaceship would be incomprehensible when
Enoch arrives in heaven the Mother Ship
he's shown a bunch of doors he calls
them 12 gates each door has a name and a
purpose he sees beings walking in and
out of the doors going about their
business Enoch calls these beings Angels
and Archangels like Uriel they radiate
light it's been suggested that these
beings could be holographic projections
though they're extremely bright Enoch
can see through them Enoch is then taken
on a tour of the cosmos he travels the
Galaxy he's shown the movement of
celestial bodies he's told about man's
place in the universe Uriel teaches
Enoch about the solar system he's told
the length of an earth year is 364 days
he's shown the lunar cycle he's shown
how constellations move across the sky
this is interesting because the Book of
Enoch was written thousands of years
before many of these discoveries were
made now you would think that there
would be nothing above heaven but
wherever Enoch is this place has a
ceiling Enoch specifically calls it a
lofty roof Enoch is taken to a giant
room full of plants that he doesn't
recognize Uriel calls it one of the
storehouses of nature now this could be
an arboretum or a garden when humans
finally travel through space there will
definitely be Gardens on their ships
Enoch has shown an object with writing
on it he calls the Book of Life he says
this records all the Deeds of man it
sounds like the angel works for the FBI
right The Book of Life is essentially a
database of surveillance
records there's a room for the wicked
Enoch describes it as a place of torture
and mutilation but this room has also
been interpreted as where alien
abductees endure experiments finally
Enoch enters the room with the Throne of
God he said there's no way to describe
or comprehend him he averts his eyes God
God tells Enoch the secrets of the
angels and the nature of the universe he
shows Enoch the different dimensions of
existence he shows Enoch visions of the
past present and the future and that's
when Enoch finally learns why he was
summoned and told to write everything
down God needs a witness he needs
someone to describe what heaven and hell
are like someone whose words will be
passed down for Generations so mankind
has a written record of the afterlife
God also needs Enoch to deliver a
message to some of God's angels on earth
and the message is not good
[Music]
news in the early days of The World God
sent 200 angels to Earth their purpose
was to observe and guard Humanity they
became known as the
Watchers typically angels are considered
Spiritual Beings but in the Book of
Enoch the Watchers are physical entities
they're described as large humanoids
some with with wings and they radiate so
much light that it's difficult to look
directly at them the Watchers taught
humans how to cultivate crops and create
Pottery they taught humans about
medicine and curing illness the Watchers
taught humans about astronomy and
astrology in ancient Samarian texts
which Enoch is probably based on 300
beings are sent to Earth from palaces in
the sky these beings are called The
Observers they too help humanity take a
Great Leap Forward we see the story in
ancient cultures all over the World
Advanced beings come down from the sky
and bring Humanity the gift of
civilization in the Book of Enoch the
Watchers helped Humanity Advance quickly
and civilizations spread but the
Watchers became Vain and proud they were
instructed by God to withhold certain
Knowledge from man the Watchers ignored
these instructions the Watchers taught
men how to create new Metals for weapons
they taught men how to harness fire and
wage war they taught women Witchcraft
and Alchemy the Watchers revealed the
secrets of the heavens and changed the
course of human development they
violated the prime directive they did
this transfer of knowledge was a
double-edged sword while it propelled
Humanity forward it also brought about
corruption a deviation from God's
order the corruption didn't just affect
men it affected the Watchers as well the
Watchers were spending more and more
time with human women uhoh this isn't
going to end well the Watchers became
lustful told you then they started
taking human women as wives for
themselves
and the angels the children of the
heaven saw and lusted after them and
said to one another come let us choose
us wives from among the children of men
and beget us children Enoch
6:1 this part of the Enoch story has
been interpreted as the human alien
hybridization program developed by the
Anunnaki in Sumerian texts in those
stories human women weren't being taken
as wives they were just being taken AB
Ed and used as incubators for a new
[Music]
species this Union of celestial and
Mortal Bloodlines gave birth to a race
of giants the Nephilim another ancient
text found in the Dead Sea Scrolls was
called The Book of Giants this book
along with the Book of Enoch described
the Nephilim as creatures of immense
size and strength and immense cruelty
the Nephilim brought even more
corruption and violence to the world
torn between Divinity and Humanity
without a home in either they go insane
soon they turn on humans and torture
anyone they can find the Nephilim needed
to consume so much food that eventually
they began feeding on human flesh humans
are helpless to stop these advances many
are enslaved by the powerful Nephilim
many more are killed then a few humans
decide to follow the example set by the
Watchers they think if angels can
torture and kill and enslave and sleep
with whoever they want why can't
we then the world becomes filled with
people like this soon God can't tell
who's a Nephilim and who isn't Enoch
delivers the message to the Watchers to
the Nephilim and to all mankind repent
for your sin or suffer the wrath of God
Enoch's warning is ignored he's brought
back to heaven where he begs God to help
save the Earth so God makes a decision
the Earth has become so corrupt and so
foul that it needs to be reset he will
cause an event so cataclysmic that
everything and everyone will be killed
humans angels Nephilim all of it gone
but one man and his family will be
spared the only man who can't be
corrupted the only man who could be
trusted to restart civilization Enoch's
great grandson Noah but here's the thing
there's a lot more to Noah than we've
been told in The Book of Enoch we get
the the full
[Music]
story in Genesis God Appears to Noah and
says the world is to end there will be a
great flood that washes away every
living thing so the world can start
again he commands Noah to build a large
boat an ark this Ark will hold Noah his
family and two of every animal in the
ark they'll survive the flood and live
to see a new age on Earth everybody
knows that story but in Enoch it happens
a little bit differently The Book of
Enoch describes Noah's
birth his body was as white as snow and
red as the blooming of a rose and the
hair of his head and his long locks were
white as wool and his eyes beautiful and
when opened his eyes he lighted up the
whole house like the sun and the whole
house was very bright the book of Noah
book 3 1 Noah is described as beautiful
with bright glowing skin and from the
moment of birth Noah can speak Noah's
father lamech panics lamech had been
away during the time Noah would have
been conceived so he knows the child
isn't his what's worse Noah is radiating
light lamech is worried that Noah is a
watcher or Worse Nephilim lamech seeks
counsel from his father Methuselah also
fearing the child could be a watcher
Methuselah prays to his own father Enoch
who's been in heaven for many years
Enoch answers Methuselah
and now make known to thy son lamech
that he who has been born is in truth
his son and call his name Noah for he
shall be left to you and he and his sons
shall be saved from the destruction
which shall come upon the Earth on
account of all the sin and all the
unrighteousness which shall be
consumated on the earth in his days the
book of Noah book 3 18 lamech is
relieved that Noah is truly his but Noah
was conceived while lamech was away in
the Book of Enoch this is a Divine
Miracle or its technology artificial
insemination and genetic manipulation a
successful human hybrid lamech also
learns that a great flood is coming and
Noah has been chosen to restart
civilization in Genesis God gives Noah
instructions on how to survive but the
Book of Enoch tells it a little
[Music]
differently
the story of Noah and the flood is
primarily found in the Book of Genesis
chapters 6-9 this narrative is one of
the most well-known in the
Bible so God said to Noah I'm going to
put an end to all people for the Earth
is filled with violence because of them
I am surely going to destroy both them
and the Earth but the Book of Enoch
tells it a little differently first it's
Uriel who tells Noah about the flood not
God and the intention of the flood is
not to destroy all humans according to
the Book of Enoch the primary targets of
the great flood are the fallen angels
known as Watchers and their human hybrid
Offspring the Nephilim most humans will
also die but this is considered
necessary collateral damage it's the
only way to reset creation and wipe the
Slate clean if some human survive great
if they don't it doesn't matter only
Noah matters Noah was given specific
instruction
on how to build the arc and
survive make yourself an ark of Cypress
Wood make rooms it and coat it with
pitch inside and out this is how you are
to build it the ark is to be 300 cubits
long 50 cubits wide and 30 cubits High
make a roof for it leaving below the
roof an opening one cubit High all
around put a door in the side of the Ark
and make make lower middle and upper
decks this is a big ship longer than a
football field almost 100 ft wide and
taller than a five-story building it
would need to be big because Noah had an
additional
responsibility you are to bring into the
ark two of all living creatures male and
female to keep them alive with you two
of every kind of bird of every kind of
animal and of every kind of creature
that moves along the ground will come to
you to be kept alive at this time in
history there were well over a million
species of animals on Earth obviously
these wouldn't fit on the ark but there
are explanations and interpretations the
biblical interpretation is that Noah
wasn't saving every breed of animal just
the type so he wouldn't have brought any
dogs he would have brought a male and
female grey wolf and the Wolves would
eventually become dogs they should have
left the kids stop it the vicious little
hell Beast there that's
enough what about huge animals like
elephants those were definitely on the
ark some biblical Scholars say the
animals delivered to Noah were infants
allowing a lot more to fit but there is
an ancient astronaut theory that says
there were no animals on the ark at all
instead it contained DNA samples of all
living creatures on Earth essential for
rebuilding civilization whether it was
God's doing or not the time finally
arrived the end of the world or the
[Music]
beginning with Noah his family and the
Animals safely aboard the ark the flood
began on that day all The Fountains of
the great deep burst open and the
floodgates of the heavens were open and
the rain fell on the earth 40 days and
40 nights as the waters raged over the
Earth anyone not on the the ark
drowned it took 5 months for the water
to recede and another five or six months
for the land to be dry enough to leave
the ark Noah and his family and the
animals were on the ark for a full year
for thousands of years Believers and
Skeptics have debated the scale of the
flood or even if it occurred at all some
have argued the biblical flood was not a
global event but a local one the best
known Theory to support this is the
Black Sea Deluge hypothesis first
proposed in 1997 it argues the Black Sea
was a freshwater lake around 260 ft
lower than it is today it was cut off
from the Mediterranean Sea by a rocky
sill in the bosor strait then around
8,400 years ago the laurentide ice sheet
collapsed causing an Abrupt sea level
jump this sent a catastrophic inflow of
Mediterranean seawat over this Natural
Dam and into the Black Sea almost 40,000
square miles of land were flooded this
significantly expanded the shoreline to
both the North and the West
200 times the flow of Niagara Falls
poured through every day and each day
the level of the Black Sea Rose several
feet and this continued for 300 days
creating the Black Sea as we know it
today undersea surveys have revealed
human made structures the remains of
freshwater fish have also been found the
memory of this massive flood could have
been passed down through the generations
then it was finally documented in flood
narratives found in both the Samarian
Epic of Gilgamesh and the book of
Genesis so there's evidence of a local
flood which would have been the entire
world to the people living there but how
about an actual Global flood a flood
that affected every part of the earth
Skeptics claim the biblical flood could
not have occurred CU there's no actual
evidence for a global flood with all
their respect those Skeptics are
[Music]
wrong many Jews Christians and Muslims
believe the great flood is symbolic an
allegory to serve as a warning to
mankind be righteous or be destroyed
others take the Bible literally and
claim Noah was a real man who built a
real boat to survive a real flood what
if they're both kind of wrong What if
there was a flood but the Man known as
Noah is known by different names in
different
cultures the ancient Samaran Epic of
Gilgamesh is the first flood story
utnapishtim is warned by the god eia
about a great flood he builds a large
boat to save his family and animals from
the Deluge sent by the god en leil and
in leil was also anunaki
right in Hinduism Manu the first man
saves a fish who later warns him of a
great flood the fish instructs Manu to
build a boat and when the flood comes
the fish guides the boat to safety
carrying Manu the seven sages and the
seeds of life in Native American ojibway
mythology a great flood occurs nanab
Bojo a cultural hero survives by
floating in a boat along with various
animals and there is an Australian
Aboriginal myth tiic a giant frog drinks
all the water in the world causing a
drought when he releases the water it
causes a great flood a boat is used to
survive this Deluge the Chinese have the
gunu flood myth which cleanse the Earth
the Inca myth tells of virocha who
floods the Earth to destroy Giants who
have disobeyed his orders sparing two to
repopulate the Earth Nephilim could be
these stories go on and on I
specifically picked a few from cultures
that are far away from each other
separated by oceans in all there are
about 250 separate flood myths but every
story is eily similar for years the
similarities between these stories was
considered coincidence as people stepped
forward to claim there really was a
global flood it was called pseudoscience
but as often happens the only difference
between pseudoscience and science is
time I think that the evidence
is consistent with a what I will call a
megascale plal event over North Africa
most likely consistent with the p toine
holine transition and the great flooding
events that we know are well documented
from other places in the world huge
tsunamis and torrential rain flooded the
entire continent of Africa reshaping the
landscape at the same time on the other
side of the world the same event here
what you have to visual ize is a tsunami
sweeping over the land that's over a
th000 ft deep that's that's what
happened here and we know that because
we can trace the the the high water
marks on the hillsides are clearly left
the high water marks are clearly etched
into the into the
hillsides this is the great flood at the
end of the younger dras where the ice
caps suddenly melted and raised the sea
level of the Earth by hundreds of
feet anyone living near a coastline
would be be gone any settlements or
cities below a certain elevation would
be destroyed the cause of this event is
still being debated some believe a large
asteroid impact or series of impacts
caused the sudden melting of the ice
another theory the one I believe is that
a massive solar flare hit the Earth this
would cause the ice to melt everywhere
at once and explain why flood myths
exist in every corner of the world
whatever caused it it was a catastrophic
event an event of biblical proportions
literally but there were survivors maybe
not just Noah maybe there were many Noah
if an asteroid or solar flare hit there
wouldn't be much time to prepare but
there would be some time maybe groups of
people anticipated the rising seas and
built boats or as some theorize and many
myths say a being came down from the sky
and warned people of the coming
catastrophe those who heeded the warning
would get to building boats right away
those that survived passed down the
story to their descendants there could
have been arcs all over the world or
maybe there really was only one Arc and
if there was where is it does it still
exist can it be found for that answer we
turn to the
CIA searches for Noah Ark have been
occurring since Antiquity but it was the
emergence of biblical archaeology in the
19th century which made the possibility
of formal searches finally feasible by
the 1940s Expeditions were organized to
follow up on potential leads as for
where the ark came to rest the Book of
Genesis gives us a hint the waters kept
receding steadily from the earth so that
they had gone down by the end of the 150
days on the 17th day of the 7th month
the ark came to rest on one of the
Mountains of
Ararat historians and biblical Scholars
agree Ararat is the Hebrew name of
urartu an Iron Age Kingdom centered
around Lake V this indicates the
mountains of arat must be found in the
eastern part of turkey near the border
of Armenia Iran and aeran aan what aan
it's fun to say I guess aan it feels
really good in the mouth aan can I get
back to this please go ahead I ain't
stopping you on
June on June 7
1949 the US Air Force was photographing
the mountains in Eastern Turkey on Mount
Ararat was a rectangular barge likee
structure west of the summit this
information was passed on to the CIA who
sent spy planes to analyze the object
that they called the Ararat anomaly what
they saw concerned them so much they
immediately classified it as secret all
subsequent photographs of the object
taken in 1956
7376 1990 and 1992 were all all
classified over the next 45 years all
requests from within the government to
see these photos were denied the photos
were never seen outside the CIA in fact
for years the CIA said the photos didn't
exist at all thanks to the Freedom of
Information Act six frames from the 1949
footage were released to the public in
1995 by 1999 the CIA finally made their
Noah's Arc files available to the public
and these documents proved that the
search for Noah's Arc had reached the
highest levels of the American
government later higher resolution
photos show no barge the 1949 picture
was most likely Iraq formation maybe
probably maybe but the Ararat anomaly is
not the only structure that looks like
Noah's Arc there is another a ship made
of solid
[Music]
Stone in October 1959 Turkish Army
Captain ilhan durupinar was on on a
mapping mission for NATO when he flew
over useni turkey he saw a strange
formation and snapped a photo when
analyzing the film he was shocked by
what he saw this structure looked a lot
like a large ship but what was a ship
doing so far inland at almost 7,000 ft
above sea level then someone decided to
measure it it was 538 ft long now that's
too big to be Noah's Arc the ark was 300
cubits long so 450 ft but wait
the length of the Cubit changed over
time the length of the Cubit that Moses
used to build the Ark of the Covenant
was different than the Cubit Noah would
have used in moses' time a cubit was
about 17 in Noah came many years before
Moses Noah was only 10 Generations from
Adam Noah would have used the Egyptian
Royal Cubit a little over 20 in the
durupinar ship was exactly 300 Royal
cubits long and 50 Royal cubits wide
this location
is exactly where the Bible said Noah
made
landfall many people think Noah landed
on Mount Ararat but that's not what the
Bible says the Bible says the Mountains
of Ararat Mount Ararat is a volcano and
has erupted a few times since the days
of Noah as recently as the 1840s in fact
geologists believe Mount Ararat is a
relatively young mountain and probably
wasn't there during the flood the
durupinar location is only a few miles
from Mount
Ararat a ground investigation was done
in the area was found about 30 drog
Stones a drog stone is a heavy rock with
a hole at the top ropes went through the
holes then they were hung from the
bottoms of ancient ships to stabilize
them in rough Seas why are there anchor
stones in the Mountains of Ararat
they're 200 mil from the closest ocean
but there they
are also on the site the ancient
settlement of nashwan was discovered
most of the evidence has been lost to
treasure Hunters but as recently as the
1970s there were Stone foundations of
ancient homes still visible this is
believed to be the first settlement
after the flood the site is so important
that there's a huge Cemetery in the area
people from all over the world requested
to be buried here not hundreds of people
not thousands as many as a million
people wanted to be buried at this
location now all that was left was to
examine the boat structure itself
researchers looked for signs of animal
remains they looked for metal nails they
looked for petrified wood they found all
[Music]
three after dupard discovered the sight
of the Ark there was an earthquake in
the area that exposed the hole of an
ancient
ship geologists visited the location and
said it's a natural formation and that
was that but in
1977 biblical researcher Ron Wyatt
renewed interest in Noah's Arc we
believe that God has preserved in the
earth and under the
Seas remains of the major events
discussed in the
Bible physical
remains over a number of years Wyatt
brought geologists and other scientists
to investigate the durupinar site oh
look at that oh wait a minute wait let
me get a closeup of
that kind of um you want my hand in
there for yeah just point at those
little flakes of iron that are coming
out like right there there and
there metal detectors were brought in
and calibrated to search for
iron not only did they find iron they
found it at regular intervals indicating
something man-made do you want a
measuring tape to measure these things
how far apart they
[Music]
are the on-site te team ran tape along
the ground where iron was
detected it was a
ship Ron Wyatt found a metallic object
next to the ark which had the shape of a
large
rivet it was surrounded by what appeared
to be an equally large metal washer part
of the metal was tested it contained a
man-made metal
alloy ground penetrating radar or GPR
was used in the 1980s
regular lines were found beneath the
surface all right the lines are
there the lines are
there this also indicates man-made
construction this data is not it does
not represent natural geology it's it's
a man-made
structure this is the West Vulcan all
right that was over there and he walked
easterly here we start getting a
longitudinal bulage here here here here
here here here here as a scientist uh do
you really honestly believe uh that you
have been on the remains of Noah's Ark I
have no no doubt in my mind
there's uh this has to be a man-made
structure it's full of metal metal is uh
has a regular pattern the size of the
thing and the shape of the thing is it's
almost certainly a large boat a small
excavation was done on the side of the
structure Wyatt's team discovered lines
of mud that were lighter in color than
the surrounding soil he believed these
to be beams from the ship as recently as
2014 3D scans were taken of the
location Not only was the shape of a
ship found it had three levels just as
the ark should the 3D scan also
confirmed the dimensions of the object
300 cubits long 50 cubits wide 30 cubits
tall a perfect
match during one demonstration for the
Turkish government Ron Wyatt pointed to
an object seen on radar near the surface
he was given permission to dig it up it
was a piece of petrified wood deck
Timber other artifacts were found at the
site more petrified wood pieces of metal
cat hair even fossilized animal dun
researchers found evidence of the fence
around Noah's house where he raised
livestock you can see the system of
fences here that appears to have been a
a system of Corrals and pens they found
the alter he used to make sacrifices to
God they even found the grave of Noah's
wife and a stone sarcophagus almost
immediately after the discovery grave
robbers stole her body and allegedly
sold it on the black market for millions
of dollars all this evidence was so
compelling that the Turkish government
officially claimed this was the place
where Noah's Ark landed there's even a
visitor center and the area is open to
the
public but if the ark really has been
found what does that mean does that mean
everything in the Bible is true were
there Angels Watchers were there
Nephilim is the Earth really much
younger than we thought and my big
question is is God the angry vengeful
God we read about in the Old Testament
there's evidence of the Ark there's
evidence of the flood if God punished
Humanity for being Wicked we should be
very careful we might want to try to be
better people we should be more kind
more honest more forgiving God already
destroyed Humanity once we're his second
try and you know what they say third
times a
[Music]
charm Noah's Ark the great flood The
Book of Enoch the Watchers the Nephilim
we covered a lot today even aliens but
is any of this true well let's work
backwards because that's the easy
easiest way to do this Ron Wyatt was not
an archaeologist he was a nurse by trade
he claimed to have all the requirements
for Masters and a PhD in Antiquities but
that wasn't true he claimed to be a
Korean War veteran and that wasn't true
he claimed to have discovered the Arc of
the Covenant but he didn't I'm always
amazed and again I don't I don't hate
Ron White I don't even really dislike
him to tell you the truth um I dislike
what he's doing I I realize that he's
deceived in my opinion uh thousands of
people he said he found the ancient
cities of Sodom and Gomorrah he didn't
ordinarily I don't say anything without
I can prove it because it's rather
embarrassing to make a statement and
somebody say well can you show me some
evidence and I can't he claimed he found
the location where Moses parted the Red
Sea he even said he found evaporated
blood of Jesus Christ he had the blood
rehydrated and examined he said Jesus's
blood had 24 chromos PMS 23 to form a
baby and one from the Holy Spirit which
proves the Virgin birth so all of his
physical characteristics were determined
by his mother's side of family her autis
a his maless was determined by this one
wife that came from the source not a
human male but this whole thing is a
lie then they
said this blood is
alive and then they said whose blood is
this
and tears would come in his eyes when he
talked about blood dripping down from
the cross to the you know on The Mercy
Seat I mean I said it's the blood of
your
[Music]
Messiah and I don't like seeing God's
work so so grossly misrepresented to um
get funds from people and to get support
from people Ron Wyatt's work is still
very popular on the internet and I can
understand why this is an incredible
story but if you look just a little
deeper you'll find statement after
statement from people who are lied to by
Wyatt and defrauded out of quite a bit
of money one patron of Wyatts lost
$30,000 on one of these holy Adventures
Wyatt said he needed another 10,000 this
Patron said only if you take a lie
detector test at first Ron Wyatt scoffed
but he needed the money he took the test
the man who administered the test said
and I quote he failed just about
everything except his name but what
about all the evidence the metal
detector's ground penetrating radar well
most of it was faked or cherry-picked
the metal detectors used weren't
professional they were purchased from
the back of treasure hunting magazines
modern professional metal detectors have
found iron at the site but it's the same
type of iron found in soil all over the
area no trained scientists has ever seen
any of the petrified wood or petrified
dung or anything like that the only
people who saw these things things were
Ron were the people paid by
Ron now the drog stones are a compelling
piece of the story because they are
there and they've clearly been there a
long time but the stone is locally
quarried drog stones from Noah's Arc
would have come from Mesopotamia not the
mountains of
turkey and the boat-shaped formation is
probably the result of a mud flow you
can see shapes like this all over the
area now supporters of ram White
theories and there are a lot of those
have answers for all of this that the
boat was actually higher up the mountain
but traveled down a lava flow but boats
don't float on lava they burn they burn
real good but thousands and thousands of
people throughout history did and do
consider this a holy place maybe Noah's
Arc was there I can't prove it wasn't
but I can prove Ron Wyatt was a
liar now as to why the CIA kept the
photos classified what was the Cold War
and these were photos from spy planes
and a few of those planes weren't
exactly in Friendly airspace after the
fall of the Soviet Union releasing the
photos wasn't a problem now the great
flood if you follow this channel you
know that I believe that really happened
and I believe it happened at the end of
the younger dras I believe a massive
solar event melted the ice caps and
created the biggest catastrophy and
human
history and if you follow this channel
you also know that the thing I fear most
is not nuclear war or civil unrest or
pandemics I fear the
sun if an asteroid is headed our way
we'll see it and we may even be able to
do something about it and if an asteroid
actually hits I believe the world would
come together and all nations would do
everything they could to help one
another but a major solar flare or
coronal mass ejection there's nowhere to
hide from that not in a mountain cave or
deep underground the Heat and radiation
would be disastrous to us and our planet
yeah we could hide underwater like the
aliens now that's true water is
effective at absorbing radiation and the
deeper you go the safer you are and I'm
sure the aliens in the ocean know that
now speaking of aliens is that what's
going on in the Book of Enoch most of
the flood myths start the same way with
a warning from a Godlike figure and they
end the same way with a Godlike figure
helping restart Civilization now I can't
definitively prove that this is true
nobody can but if we keep pressuring our
governments about uaps and UFOs we may
eventually get some answers Humanity did
take a leap forward in technology many
thousands of years ago and maybe those
ancient humans had
help Enoch physically goes to a place
that sounds like a spaceship the Prophet
Elijah also talks about riding a chariot
of
fire what I thought you were going to
sing it again well now I don't want
to Elijah talks about riding a chariot
of fire over the Earth with a humanlike
being Elijah is Amazed by the sound of
the vehicle and how fast it moves other
cultures and religions have similar
stories Muhammad ascends to heaven and
meets Allah before returning to Earth in
Hinduism Arjuna is taken to heaven and
lives there for a few years before
coming back down there are many more of
these myths but are they myths maybe
these things did actually happen happen
but they're written down as myths
because the technology is so far ahead
of what existed at the time maybe these
were visitations and
abductions there's a tribe in West
Africa called the Doan and there are
about a 100,000 of them who mostly live
in caves and cliffs they're still A
Primitive people the doot religion says
that long ago they were visited by
aliens from the Syria star system these
aliens told the Doan that they helped
the Egyptians the Greeks and the
Sumerians with their civilization
but what's really amazing is the Doan
are aware of the star serus B which the
tribe calls poo Serius B is invisible to
the naked eye it was first discovered in
1862 but the Dogan people had no
telescopes they still don't yet not only
were they aware of the star Serius B
they knew it was a white dwarf companion
star to the much brighter Sirius a the
Doan knew the length of Sirius B's orbit
in years they knew the shape of its
orbit they knew it was a Dense Star they
relayed all this information to a
visiting Anthropologist in the 1930s
they even said there's a third star in
the serious system but there wasn't
until there was in 1995 a study
concluded that a third companion star
exists more recent studies aren't so
sure but the Doan people are allegedly
the Doan were also aware of Jupiter's
moons and Saturn's rings now Skeptics
like to poke holes in the Dogan story
and I think that's fine like the dgon
were wrong about the number of Jupiter's
moons but they were right about Sirius
B the story of Enoch seems to be based
on Ancient Samaran stories like a lot of
the Bible is when people talk about the
Book of Enoch they're referring to
what's officially called first Enoch
because there are three books biblical
Scholars consider the books of Enoch
pseudepigrapha that is a Biblical work
that falsely claims authorship by a
Biblical character that doesn't mean the
books of Enoch weren't known or weren't
important in fact first Enoch is quoted
in Jude
14-15 Enoch was known and was important
but the book is not considered inspired
by God and therefore is apocryphal and
not part of Canon still a page turner oh
yeah it's a good read now some parts of
Enoch are said to have been written
later to expand on stories from the
Bible like the birth of Noah and Enoch's
visit to Heaven these were interesting
characters and people wanted to learn
more so someone or many someone ones we
don't know who just wrote more yeah it's
like Bible fan fiction it's exactly like
that but different religions and
denominations are going to have
different interpretations remember the
Ethiopian Orthodox Church says the book
is Canon and that church has been around
for almost 3,000 years some Christians
think reading the book is heresy a crime
against the church but most Scholars
consider the Book of Enoch an important
text that gives additional insight into
the lives and beliefs of the people
living at the time honestly whether the
Book of Enoch is Canon or not that's not
important to me it's an interesting
academic discussion as you know I'm not
religious but I am fascinated by and
have great respect for religions all
religions I enjoy the stories and for
the most part I think they teach good
lessons I'm more into fishes and Loaves
than fire and brimstone but that's just
my taste but I know I'm going to hear it
in the comments every time I do a
religious story I get attacked in the
comments there's going to be people
screaming at me in all caps to take
Jesus into my heart or I'm going to hell
if that's what you believe that's okay I
don't believe that I don't know what
happens after we die I'm inclined to say
nothing just black but there's a big
piece of my heart that really wants to
be wrong because when I finally pass on
and walk down that tunnel if I'm greeted
by family and friends long past and I
find myself standing at the Pearly Gates
the first words out of my mouth are
going to be thank God
thank you so much for hanging out with
us today my name is AJ that's Heckle
fish peace be unto the human grateful am
I for thine eyes that have watched and
thine ears that have heard this has been
the wi files if you had fun or learned
anything do him a favor subscribe
comment like share hitting the buttons
really helps us out and like most topics
we cover on the channel today's was
recommended by you so if there's a story
you'd like to see or learn more about go
to the Wi files.com tips and remember
the yfiles is also a podcast twice a
week I post deep dives into the stories
we cover here on the channel I also post
episodes that wouldn't be allowed on the
channel it's called the yfiles operation
podcast and it's available everywhere
you get your podcasts now if you need
more wi files in your life cuz who
doesn't check out our Discord server
there are thousands of people I think
we're up to 35,000 members well there's
thousands of people on there 24/7 and
they're into the same weird stuff that
we are it's a great Community it's a lot
of fun and it's free to join a special
thanks to our patrons who make this
channel possible every episode is
dedicated to you and as you know I could
not do this without your support so
thank you and if you'd like to support
the channel we'd love you to become a
member on patreon for as little as $3 a
month you get access to perks like you
see the videos early with no commercials
you get access to merch only available
to Members Plus you get two private live
streams every week just for you another
great way to support the channel is grab
something from the wifi store come forth
and partake in our wayes for in your
hands they shall find purpose and
through your stewardship their Journey
shall be fulfilled what does that mean
grab a heck ofish t-shirt a fible mug or
a de ofo Heckle fish cards or a hookie
or what it is that a hookie a hoodie and
what of those squeezy stuffed animal
Heckle Fish Talk fish toy that's going
to do it until next time be safe be kind
and know that you are
[Music]
appreciated
oh
yeah I play Bia Scara 51 a secret code
inside the Bible said
I I love my UFOs and paranomal fun as
well as music so singing the like
[Music]
IA within another conspiracy theory he
becomes the truth my
friends and it never
ends no it never
[Music]
ends I feel the crap cat I got stuck
inside M's hole with MK truck I being
only true a
away did Stanley Cub brick fake the moon
landing alone on a film set with the
shadow people
there throughout well aliens just fought
the smiling man I'm
told and his name was
cold I can't believe I'm dancing with
the
fish fish On th night
wedn the
night all I ever wanted was to do hear
the truth to the one all through the
[Music]
night the MTH man siding and the solar
storm still come to have got the the
secret City Underground
mysterious number stations planet to
project State and where the dark
Watchers
found a simulation don't
you the black KN satellited to me so I
can't believe I'm dancing with the
F fish on thday night
they the
night all I ever wanted was to just hear
the
truth all through the
night fish on Thursday night Wednesday J
you and my me all through the
night all I ever want you just hear the
truth so the one bat all through
the
dance love
dance dance good dance good loves to
dance lovees to dance on the dance ball
because she is a camel and camels love
to dance when the feeling is right on
wasting
time love Dan SC like
[Music]
Dan